hey everyone it's Michael Volos here
from order flows.com and this is the
orderflows market analysis for Tuesday
April 18 2017 before we get disc started
a brief disclaimer this presentation is
for educational and informational
purposes only and should not be
considered a solicitation to buy or sell
a Futures Contract or make any other
type of investment decision Futures
training contains substantial risk and
is not for every investor an investor
could potentially lose all or more than
the initial
investment risk capital is money that
can be lost without jeopardizing one's
Finance security or lifestyle only risk
Capital should be considered should be
used for trading only those with
sufficient risk Capital should consider
trading fast performance is not
necessarily indicative of future results
again you know the reason why there are
uh disclaimers like this at the
beginning of my presentations because I
don't want people coming in thinking
they know that what I show them in the
examples is um 100% accurate there are
times that trades fail um you know I do
try and show that when that happens and
you know trading is not easy easy
trading involves work right don't don't
think you're going to come to the
markets and all of a sudden you know buy
a $40,000 watch next week um you know
maybe if you start with a million
dollars yeah next week you could buy a
$440,000 watch because that's all you
got left but uh you know realistically
you know the best Traders you know they
put in the effort you know they put in
the work and it's not something that
happens overnight for many people and
you know if if people are are selling
you some Black Box Thing thinking that
it's going to make uh all tons of money
you know overnight then uh you know I
got a bridge to sell you or some swamp
land in Florida now the tools that are
used in this presentation are the
orderflows trader which is a volume
footprint chart and you know i' I've
enhanced it a bit um to take into
account what I look at and what I use in
the orderflow again you know my charts
make orderflow trading a lot easier um
you know it was designed for me
specifically then people asked you know
how can they get a copy and you know I
didn't set out to become a software
vendor you know I I I don't like it per
se you know I'd rather concentrate on on
the markets myself rather than you know
answering support tickets and and things
like that but you know that said um you
know there is value in using orderflow
and you know part of me you know I take
it upon myself to educate people on on
how to use orderflow you know there's a
lot of garbage information out there and
you know hopefully by watching my videos
you could pick up some of the uh
insights that I've acquired in in my 20
years of of Trad tring you know when I
say 20 years of trading it's not 20
years of trading for myself you know in
my uh home office you know I I was
working at the biggest firms in the
world JP Morgan I spent eight years
there Cargill I spent four years there
um Commerce Bank three years there EDF
man two years you know and before that I
was on the CME floor so this is solid
legitimate you
know um I don't want to call it not
education but you know work experience
and you know how many people out there
that are are you know teaching people
how to trade you know have that
experience you know not many um you know
but again you know I I feel like I I
have a a duty to you know help people
learn how to trade properly um you know
some some of my friends think I'm crazy
for wanting to spend time with um you
know beginning Traders and you know you
know because it's frustrating honestly
sometimes but you know at the end of the
day you know I I feel good that you know
people are able to make this make the
change you know um you know not
everybody comes to the market markets
looking to make uh you know a million
dollars next week you know some people
are are just happy to make you know $200
a day in the markets and you know if I
can help them then then great you know
$200 a day is doesn't sound like much
but you know over the course of a month
you know that's a huge difference in
person's income and you know there's
nothing nothing wrong with with starting
small you know I mean it's it's a little
bit I'll say less stress but um you know
anytime you got money on the on the line
there is stress but you know you got to
start small and again there's nothing
wrong you know I said for a lot of
people $200 a day at the end of the
month you know is their house payment
their car payment you know kids tuition
it's a decent uh you know it's a decent
way to earn uh you know a second income
you know especially if you're retired or
something I'm not saying all retirees
got to do it but you know what for
people that are looking another way to
supplement their
income and have the time during the day
to sit in front of a screen for a few
hours um you know orderflow you know
trading the markets might be for you um
you know I W say might be but uh you
know there's I can't say you know
everybody it's for everybody you know
because honestly you know trading is not
for everybody there's a small percentage
of people out there that you know can
make it work and you know not everybody
is is going to be successful in trading
you know I I don't want to say that you
know everybody's got a 100% success rate
but you know it's just like any other
field you know we we all take uh you
know when you're when you're when you're
a kid you you take you play soccer you
know not everybody is going to be become
a professional soccer player yeah some
people will get good some people will
get the skills that you know will sit
with them and they could play soccer you
know on a decent level and you know
that's what I'm trying to teach you is
how to trade on a decent level how to
survive in the markets and make money
you know it's all about making money and
being consistent and I think orderflow
will help a lot of Traders become
consistent so that said let's uh jump
into some charts here um the first one I
I'll talk about this morning well sorry
this it's in the evening time but um
you know what happened was uh here this
first one is going to be in the bond
market here just pull it in here so you
can see it a bit
easier
and where we was a little bit early in
this session there was a couple
interesting things here in the bonds
this morning so you know just coming
into the US session you know the nice
thing in the bonds you had this
Divergence you had a ratio and again you
know ratio and Divergence it's that's
like a a go-to trade for me um you know
your ratios here it's in blue numbers
again you know if you're not familiar
with my orderflow ratios you know a lot
of people have been adapting these and
they don't explain it properly but if
you get my software you know I've got a
I've got some I got a short PDF that
explains you know how to use them um you
know if it's a red bar it's on top if
it's green bar it's underneath and if
it's a blue number you know you like it
if it's a black number it's just average
you know your your average order flow in
the market you know not every bar is
going to be so revealing to you that you
know the the Mysteries of the world are
going to be solved in the bar no um but
there are times when you know something
in the orderflow stands out and that's
what you're going to look for in the um
in the ratio so here you have a
Divergence you have a new high with a
negative Delta in our ratio and we sold
off quite nicely from the uh you know
1542 area down to 15324 you know this
was just you know by it's a little bit
early though 545 that had happened until
about 6:30 but uh you know if you're
front of your screens you would have
been rewarded now another thing um you
know don't think you know just because
you have a Divergence you know where you
have a new high and a negative Delta
that you know hey it's a go you know
it's it's um Red Light Green Light no
you should take it you know with the
orderflow you know again you don't have
here you had a blue number in the ratio
so it's a ratio I like here's it's not
it's black right here it's black here
it's black and you'll notice each time
these divergences
fail and when you start getting you know
groupings of failed divergences often
times it's a sign that um you know the
market could run higher and we do you
know you got three fail divergences
basically from 748 to 839 so less than
an hour and then a little bit later the
strength reappears Market makes new
highs so you had a sign actually earlier
that you know here at 8 you know just
for 840 that this Market you know if we
start making runs at the highs again
watch out we could go higher and we do
you know we got some new highs again
failed divergences again we keep running
higher
here um get up here again you got
another um ratio with a Divergence you
know
28.412730
which is another type of setup and you
know we just go higher from there until
uh 2:00 which is when the cash closed so
that was the bonds now um another market
I'll look at really quick is the uh is
the fives you know five years trade
similar to the bonds it's not exactly
100% uh the same because you know
obviously the bonds is more of a 20-year
even though it's a 30-year contract it's
more of a 20-year note that's based on
um but that
said
the uh five years you know did give some
similar uh things again here you have a
failed ratio with a Divergence again you
know not every time it
works get up here you got a a ratio now
it's 74 right IED I used to use Point uh
1.0 but i' I've tightened it up to 7 you
know this is just on the cusp of it
there's a couple other things you know
you got this buying imbalance here at
the new high and you you get one tick
follow through and then it fails
actually you know for me this is quite
telling um you know you got the
aggressive buyers coming in here it
couldn't take it any higher took it one
tick higher then it failed you got the
selling imbalance here here here I know
it sort of lights out this high for the
meantime at least and then you sell off
um you know a few ticks then again you
get back up to this high this time you
do have the uh ratio 277 it's a blue
number with a Divergence yeah you come
off a little bit then it just starts
coming back again you know again this
one you know you would have taken a
small loss on that I'm not going to
sugar coat it and say oh yeah you could
have broken even no you know I'd be
looking to get short somewhere in here
around 23 and
A4 and you know it makes the move down
to
222 before it starts turning back up you
know that's the sign to get out before
you get stopped out up here is is this
um single print here you know with a
bullish ratio you know you don't want to
be looking you don't want to be short
and then all a sudden start to see
bullish signals you know on the way back
up here you get a another uh Divergence
but no ratio you got the price rejector
given a sell there um again some more
failed dices you know happening pretty
quick 1 2 3 um you know that's that's a
sign the market can go higher you know
you got from 927 to 1011 within 30
minutes uh sorry you know about 40
minutes three failed
divergences and you know when you have
failed divergences grouped together it's
it's often a sign of the market bumping
higher bumping higher bumping higher
coming off a little bit buying coming
back in making it go higher and then
boom we just go higher higher higher
then uh that was about it I think in the
in the FES this morning yeah then um
this the evening session
already um you know lastly or not lastly
there's a couple more markets I'll talk
about real quick
um The e- Minis uh really quick okay so
this is the e- mini daily chart okay and
you know what you got here the day
before this is well we're in the evening
session right now so you got that small
candle this is yesterday this is the
18th rather trade date the 18th is trade
date the 17th so this is Monday big
engulfing pattern right where all the C
stick guys engulfing pattern you know
sell you know mortgage the house uh get
a you know loan on the car just buy the
[__] out of this market right you got
this you know you're coming down you got
a swing low got a bullish engulfing
pattern get the long get the hell long
where what happened we didn't do [__]
right we just we rallied a little bit
made a new high sold off Under Pressure
most of the day so you know all the
Candlestick guys and again you know it's
not like a few people look at
candlesticks a [__] a fuckload of people
look at cand candlesticks
and you know that that was quite obvious
in the morning you know all all you know
basically since the close of Monday they
you're sitting on this big bullish
engulfing pattern where you know what
happened it failed right I mean I was
honestly in the morning I I was looking
when we started rallying here I said hey
maybe you know we're going to see some
continuation for me the key would have
been if if we got up to 50 I think we
could have pushed up another 5 10 points
um you know to validate this um bullish
engulfing pattern we didn't we failed
okay so you know what to do um you know
candlesticks are great when they work
when they don't work U you know you
don't you don't hear a peep out of the
Candlestick eyes and just uh you know go
hide back in their caves but um you I
say that I I used to I like candlesticks
don't get me wrong I like candlesticks
but um you know when they fail they fail
I mean just like any other just like any
other
indicator so the next one that I'm going
to look at here is is the 10 range e
mini and you know honestly this morning
it was kind of uneventful actually in
the minis we had a very wide value area
you know coming into the morning but a
little bit later uh around
11: you had this interesting thing you
had three in a row one you know three
ratios in a row you got the pullback
which I was looking for you know a pull
back up to this point of control now
however the only thing that throws the
spanner in the works is one I don't
necessarily like to be getting short
going into new lows you know even though
I got you know a three in a row you know
rather what I me personally you know
every Trader is wired differently I'm
always looking for a reason to be buying
it near a low if possible and I get it I
got the ratio I got the Divergence right
here and you know this trumps this all
right so even though you're looking at
this three in a row sell down here I got
a buy I got a very strong buy and you
got to make decision do what are you
going to do you're going to stick with
this you know if you got short in here
you know up here somewhere on this point
of control it just went sideways on you
so even if you got short you know you
wouldn't have been damaged too much you
could have taken either small loss or
broken even I'm not saying yeah you
would have sold it here could be looking
to sell around you between these two
pointer controls um you know so if
you're getting short in here you know
I'm not going to say you could covered
it down here and made a point now that's
[__] most likely you would have
broke even or taken a a small loss but
this to me this is you know this is the
thing you got to buy it and you know
what happened over the you know it just
went from um you know 33 all the way up
into uh you know into the 40s you know
that was the the nice big
trade and lastly what I'll talk about
here is the soybeans soybeans was
interesting I love beans and you know
that goes back to my days of of trading
at Carill traded
Commodities and it was interesting you
know 8:30 when the uh you know 8:30 is
like the official you know this the
official open day session open even
though it trades electronically and it
closes and then it reopens it at 830
look at this all selling look at all
these Deltas 353 500 300 200 500 look at
this candles all negative all selling
all down get a bounce here still still
negative Delta get another bounce here
it's a ratio but no Divergence again
negative Delta then you get down to this
bar your first bar with positive Delta
since 8:30 it's 9:00 first uh sign of
buying off the lows right here okay um
you know it is Divergence it's not a
ratio then you get a bearish ratio here
you get the price the Delta scalper
coming in right here but look at this
right so you got some buying coming in
here 269 okay then 61 it's getting
smaller then Delta of eight and eight
eight and eight eight is nothing in a
bar you know that's the difference in
one trade you I could have come in and
bought 10 Lots or sold 10 lots and would
be looking at negative Delta so I I
treat these numbers it's kind of
neutral um you know um it's just it's
not strong and I don't want to say it's
not weak but you know it's just kind of
neutral in here 8 and8 it's said it
could easily be a negative Delta with
just one or two two more trades and then
the selling comes in boom you got the
Delta scalper given a huge cell here
I'll say a huge cell but they given a
cell you got a huge negative Delta again
strong negative Delta strong negative
Delta and of course what what happens
you go into the new
lows Divergence here okay what
shortlived and then boom right down here
low of the day strong negative Delta - 7
it's it's your your most it's your
strongest negative Delta of the day now
this is where it gets interesting this
is where looking at the order flow
really helps you as a Trader what do you
see in this bar okay yeah you see the
strong negative Delta candle's Green
Market turned up why because you got a
lot of support here 449 500 499 right
here this is why you have the strong
negative Delta you know people are still
selling you know these are I want say
the last sellers but you know these are
all all the retail guys that are coming
in that miss this move lower thinking
hey we're going lower going to hit limit
down sell it sell it you know but
there's there's a strong commercial
buyer here I say commercial it could be
institutional it could be whatever um
all I know is there's some strong
support here 400 you know 1,500
contracts right here and you know that's
why you have that negative Delta because
they're selling the [__] into it um you
know 719 negative Delta and what happens
the support holds start to Rally
positive Delta positive Delta come back
down come back down to this level look
at this level what is it right here you
know just at this point of control I
mean it's not exactly the point of
control it's one tick below the point of
control but more or less you know this
point of control is holding you know
here we get down again another another
uh you know one tick through it you know
this bar here is is holding you have the
point of control in this bar here at the
low just right off the low at 940 we
don't even get down there and we just
pop back all the way up from you know
942 is all the way up into you know all
the way up to the close um you know
there's the close up in here around 946
and A5 947 and we're into the night
session
so you know that that was it for the day
on on you know these these markets in
the uh on the orderflow I mean it's I
said it's not rocket science there is
some science behind it um you know the
theory of supply and demand is what move
markets you know not mathematical
equations and you know if you're willing
to take the time to you know learn more
about
orderflow you know it's going to help
your trading I've got a webinar tomorrow
on the 19th if you haven't signed up for
it you know you can go the link I put in
the description below and you know it's
it's definitely worth learning more
about orderflow if you're not using
orderflow so you know thanks for
watching this and to learn more about
the software using this presentation how
you can profit from orderflow Trading
visit my website www. orderflows
thatcombines
in the afternoon it's like at 1:15
Chicago time at least sign up for it so
when it's done you know you'll get a
link for the replay if you don't you
could always email me but at least then
you can watch the replay and we be
talking about how to use orderflow with
you know like bowling your bands how to
use it with um or just how to how to
find lowrisk trades basically now I'm
going to talk about my my three tick uh
stop trade you know where you could risk
as little as three ticks on a trade and
you know yesterday well I S you know in
the crude oil I just really quick I'll
give you a a a preview of tomorrow you
know this this right here I'm going to
talk about this in the
webinar so you have this High here this
is around
9:00 you I'm going to show you how you
could have gotten short around the 52 82
is area and made a move all the way down
to you know 52 you know below 5260 so
those 20 ticks right there you're
risking just three ticks you know how
you can sell this high with confidence
so so again you know if um you want to
learn more about orlow if you want to
learn this specific trade setup watch my
uh watch my webinar tomorrow so thanks
all and I hope to see you on the webinar
byebye